قالت الشرطه الامريكيه ان تسعه اشخاص
قتلوا باطلاق نار خلال احتفالات السنه
الصينيه الجديده في مدينه مونتيري بارك
بولايه كاليفورنيا الامريكيه وذكرت صحيفه
لوس انجلوس تايمز ان الحادثه وقعت قرب
موقع للاحتفال بالعمل القمري الصيني
الجديد حيث شارك عشره الاف في المهرجان
الذي اقيم في وقت سابقا يوم امس وقد اظهرت
اللقطه المصوره فرض الشرطه طوقا امنيا في
مكان الحدث
اذا هذه الصور مباشره ايضا من مونتري بارك
التي
حدثت فيها
تلك التطورات
اندلعت احداثه عنف في مدينه اتلانتا
الامريكيه في اعقابي احتجاجاتنا على مقتل
شاب تقول الشرطه انه بدر باطلاق النار على
افرادها الذين ردوا عليه وارضه قتيلا
المحتجون الذين كانوا يطالبون بالتحقيق في
مقتل الشاب البالغ من العمر 26 عاما اشعل
النيران في سياره شرطه وحطم نوافذ محل
تجاريه في المدينه
هذا وقد اعتقلت الشرطه عددا من المحتاجين
بينما دعا حاكم جورجيا وعمده المدينه الى
التهدئه
وانتظاري نتائج التحقيق
[موسيقى]